welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Merridew Wray an
associate professor in the history
department at Yale professor rise
doctoral research focused on the
problems of religion politics and
protest in modern Kashmir it culminated
in her book hindu rulers Muslim subjects
Islam rights and the history of Kashmir
she is here to talk with us today about
her new research in the region of Bihar
India that explores the relationships
between caste territory region and
nation as they evolved from the period
of British colonial rule into the
post-colonial era
welcome professor Rai thank you very
much for having me here so in your
newest book which you are currently in
the process of writing you look at the
caste system in India specifically in
the region of Bihar
what is caste an interesting question of
a broad question
the term cast itself is has no Indian
origin it's derived from the Portuguese
term Casta and yet of course the
phenomenon of caste is very Indian it's
marked as one of the essences according
to some writers of Indian society itself
the phenomenon of caste derives
literally from ancient times in India
itself a verse in the ancient text the
Rigveda composed in roughly 1200 BC
mentions the division of society along
four lines and a hierarchical division
of society that had Brahmins the
priestly office acid dojo classes at the
top the chakras the warrior caste a
second in rank the ratios those
producing the wealth of society merchant
groups richer land owning groups third
and rank and then a category called
Shudras sort of providing menial
as forth and rank eventually through the
history of India a fifth category was
added namely that of the untouchables
quote-unquote who again the origins of
untouchability and these untouchable
groups is varied and and fully explained
in the history but these five divisions
in fact simply form the theoretical peg
against which another category must be
added that of jothee
jothee literally means birth and when
indians talk about caste they actually
allude to that concept of jati and by
some surveys they're about three
thousand jetties in India and they seem
to be pegged in various ways against
this four and then five fold division
along the lines of caste what is
important to remember is that of course
these are not set categories they're not
deprived of history that over the
centuries of the existence of these
categories there's been a great deal of
mobility both upwards and downwards
however if we look at cast in the early
21st century it certainly represents a
certain a very distinct sort of
hierarchical division certainly amongst
Hindus but caste has actually had this
strange sort of effect of permeating
into different religious groups and
religious communities that have existed
in the subcontinent as well so in India
you could even think of Brahmin
Christians and Shu there are Christians
Islam which is such an egalitarian
religion also in its in the social
existence of Muslim communities displays
some of these these notions of
hierarchical ranking so in some ways
it's it's cost as we understand it today
is literally a certain kind of
hierarchical ranking
that seems peculiar to the South Asian
subcontinent
it doesn't match up with categories of
class mobility has become more
restricted and that that sort of removal
of flexibility within caste D is dated
to the more modern period of India's
history and what drew you to this topic
again you know as I said this is a
highly hierarchical system and some of
the hierarchies are maintained through
extreme violence in in contemporary
India for instance the the subordination
that is subjected that is to which lower
caste groups are subjected is is violent
it's it's it's shockingly violent but
yet is commented upon very rarely we're
more used to specially sitting in the
West were more used to thinking about
the Indian subcontinent in terms of the
more usual rivalry rivalry story along
religious lines Hindu versus Muslim or
national lines India vs. Pakistan
Sinhala versus Tamil linguistic regional
lines caste is is is addressed as the
essence of India but not discussed
enough I think there is a quick Didion
kind of violence that characterizes the
operation of caste itself and this is
despite the fact that the Indian
Constitution enacted finally in 1950
framed and given to the people of Indian
in 1949 abolished untouchability through
various articles it abolished the
principle of discrimination along the
lines of caste so in principle the state
in India does not recognize caste and
yet the history of India has shown that
caste far from fading away has returned
to the fold of
politics in India itself and those
politics are have produced remarkable
results I mean we have in the the most
popular state of India the state of
Uttar Pradesh we have a woman Chief
Minister
first of all gender in terms of gender
itself this is a remarkable change but
cheese also I mean again South Asia the
subcontinent is familiar with sort of
women and power but this is a woman who
comes from in fact the most subordinated
groups from in fact an untouchable group
and yet the violence alone caste lines
the daily brutalities that are meted out
to to people along the sort of the lower
rungs of this hierarchy that still
exists is not acknowledged often enough
so for me you know I remember hearing
that almost 18,000 people died Dalits
Untouchables subordinated groups died
and violence meted out to them in just
the space of a decade was shocking
enough and yet that it wasn't recognized
okay so let's talk about your book what
is the premise um okay I'm I'm a
historian and I'm trying to navigate
actually uh between sort of enormously
weighty
scholarship I would summarize the sort
of the debates within that scholarship
along I separated along to very broadly
put lines one school of thought that
says that well caste of course existed
before the British arrived in India but
colonial rule turned it into a system
that it that you know the mechanisms of
establishing colonial rule through
institutions like taking the census on a
decennial basis through sort of making
available political power a long lines
of gastrin religious belonging
sort of turned what was a much more
variegated system a much more variegated
phenomenon rather into a system that
begins to apply on the all-india sort of
landscape as it were and then there's
another body of scholarship equally
weighted equally important that says
well certainly British rule changed some
of the premises within which gas began
to function as a system but the colonial
state certainly did not invent caste
that in fact it predated the arrival of
the British I'm trying to navigate my
Holi between these very very sort of
serious blocks of scholarship and if I
may use a shorthand for me I think after
a point it matters little who invented
cast into a system what is interesting
to me is that is to find out how its
experienced what does it mean when you
look beyond the colonial state I can be
no one's argument that a caste didn't
exist before the British arrived in
India and it can certainly be no one's
argument that the British didn't
actually transform all kinds of social
imaginings including that of caste but
but how was it actually experienced so
for me I want to move away from a line
of thinking but still I mean no matter
how how disparate and then sort of
oppositional these two perspectives
might seem both agree that something
happens under colonial rule that changes
the way in which caste affects Indians I
take a line that says well yes but you
know to understand cast cast functions
even as leaders in the late 19th century
when the colonial state has since it's
in enumeration that makes cast into a
reality even then what is changing is
literally the spaces within which gas
functions
um castor makes no sense outside of
locality I want to bring in this whole
notion of ideas of mutuality and
reciprocity that cast always existed I
take as a premise relations based along
a hierarchy of casts always existed in
localities what changes is a the the
arena within which suddenly caste
domination has to be asserted through
violence I want to ask why you can I
mean by the late 20th century and
certainly even earlier than that by the
early 20th century why does it take
violence to maintain caste but for
centuries there was a quieter violence I
mean I'm I do not believe that caste was
ever a benevolent institution that you
know the caste is touched through and
through by oppression is is evident that
it is touched through and through by
subordination is evident but how do we
explain the fact that you know today it
takes the form of warfare and I want to
argue that in fact what is happening
through the late 19th century is not so
much a greater amplification of caste
identities that it's something else that
in fact caste identities always existed
what is happening is in fact perhaps a
fragmentation of the localities the
communities within which caste had
always demanded both mutuality and
reciprocity even in a system that is
highly unequal that it was possible for
lower caste to say wait hang on I call
upon you to fulfill your duties
something begins to change in in in a
chic societies throughout northern India
through the late 19th century whereby in
fact upper castes don't have to maintain
that pattern of mutuality they function
in a different arena
so why did you select the region of
Bihar an easy answer would be first of
all that I'm from be hard but that's too
easy an answer because my first work had
nothing to do with be hard it had to do
with cush me be hard well I mean part of
the answer is indeed that I'm from the
heart it's a question of wanting to tap
into a whole variety of sources in the
vernacular in a sort of the more high
standard Hindi and will do that I can
access most of all because Bihar is
deemed to be that single region in the
Indian subcontinent that is a rat rat by
gas violence even more tragically I mean
a thousands of deaths occur and be hard
along the lines or ostensibly in the
name of caste violence but it is deemed
to be natural to be hard
nobody surprised by this I speak to
friends of mine and say did you see that
story in in Bihar I mean upper caste
just burned down the villages of you
know sort of at least two villages and
beheaded 23 people and you know it
shocked me to hear their reaction saying
Yahoo Bihar right
it happens in Bihar why yous are so
surprised by it I wanted to investigate
that Bihar is deemed to be this province
that has no regional identity that it's
a that any sense of commonality along
the lines of region language constantly
founders on the lines of caste my first
book actually on Kashmir sort of
explored a different dimension saying
wait in the case of Kashmir people
always talk about a regional identity
that overcomes constantly in this
miraculous way religious divisions Hindu
versus Muslim it all forgotten until it
goes sour
Bihar on the other hand is the opposite
case it's always spoken of as the
opposite case
but region that can is incapable of a
regional identity where caste is
overwhelming so for me in some ways that
was a point of curiosity that groove
literally from my first work again as I
said I mean in be hard cause violence is
deemed to be endemic people don't use
the term caste violence they use the
term caste warfare and we're talking
about upper caste groups with their own
private armies that that sort of that
are deployed to to extract the labor and
services of lower cost or subordinated
caste groups who resist that
exploitation so that there's some
legitimacy to using that term warfare if
you're talking about armies it's
suddenly gas seems to be the only sort
of sort of characteristic of that
province of behind and I thought that
would be a very good place to begin as I
said I mean I I come from there and and
literally I thought it would be and the
questions are raised literally from my
first work itself let's talk about your
research can you give us some ideas of
what you need to do in terms of pulling
information together in data
he was very with it's been an
interesting experience as I said part of
the temptation of working on be hard was
the fact that you know I actually had I
have a thorough knowledge of the
vernacular of the region so I've had a
an interesting time trying to move from
my training as a as a historian that has
so far allowed me to look at colonial
sources and those are available
plentifully between the National
Archives in New Delhi and the British
library's own sort of India office
library archival material I certainly
use those I access those with with with
great abandon and enjoy doing that but
this time I've been trying to sort of
supplement
material with vernacular sources such as
poetry and especially if you're trying
to retrieve a sense of how cast has
experienced rather than that debate that
I'd spoken about earlier in terms of
well did the colonial state invented or
was there something that preceded it
well experiencing cast requires actually
culling material produced by ideally
subordinated groups but of course you're
talking about groups that don't leave a
written record but I've had enormous
good luck and I see at least retrieving
sort of you know a jar of poetry
produced by a migrant migratory labor
groups it's amazing I mean they are sent
out a fast section of its population
outside of the state but it's such an
impoverished state large numbers of men
would and women would leave to find work
in Calcutta so I've been used out
actually in they would be a you know a
former major section of the indentured
labour that was sent out to Fiji and
Mauritius etc some of them actually left
records um in the form of poetry letters
I've been using those kinds of materials
to actually try and call a sense of what
it meant to feel the burden of caste not
a scarf but caste as a lived experience
the exploitation where you know where it
is but you might find justice actually
my work literally is titled geographies
of justice it's actually it's an attempt
to retrieve those spaces not
geographical spaces necessarily but
those mental and geographical spaces
where you are allowed to invoke a sense
of justice to sort of correct the wrongs
that are visited upon you by this thing
that we talked about so easily as the
caste system itself so so it's been it's
been a challenging bit of
research but I've enjoyed it that it is
and in terms of your the premise of your
book in the end what do you think your
research will find I think at the end of
the day as I hope to complicate this
issue of you know how cast is thought
about if you don't look at the
localities within which cast functions I
mean the Constitution of India I think
in abolishing untouchability or
abolishing discrimination along the
lines of caste is it was very right
headed it it I mean the the message was
certainly one to be applauded but that's
what is you know that that's a message
that comes on from on high how it gets
implemented on the ground requires a
certain understanding of how caste
functions
literally on the ground and on the
ground I mean no matter how much gas may
have been constructed by the colonial
state into a an all-india white system I
still find that actually caste is
manifest in localities I I want to
suggest that you know even if you take
the the region of the heart itself
that's that's too large to be a locality
but that's certainly bringing the debate
down to a region within that region I
think if you begin to look at the way in
which caste actually I mean what went
wrong is not the emphasis of cost but
the breakdown in patterns of a sort of
interrelationship that had placed caste
groups in close social proximity to each
other that fragmenting of that proximity
is is I think what allowed certain caste
groups to to meet violence on other gods
groups I hope that this research
suggests that you know well hang on that
that's the way to begin to correct it I
mean caste hasn't disappeared no matter
what you know what the Indian
Constitution says no matter how that
message is carried forth by by you know
high minded civil servants as
they conduct the business of the states
in at the level of the small district in
the village it hasn't disappeared it and
it won't disappear simply by wishing it
away I hope that my my work sort of
shows the sort of you know the the the
relationships the tiny but very vital
relationships that both kept costs in
together again always an unequal
relationship certainly but the
corrective is keeping them together not
not prising them apart or not blinding
ourselves to the fact that well you know
of 61 years from Independence in there
it still sort of beset by the nightmare
of of caste violence as I said I mean I
was shocked to find that a figure like
18,000 incidences of violence
perpetrated against the Dalits the
ground down louis gossett india and i
hope that this work is a contribution to
sort of at least understanding the way
in which that relationship works and
what makes it fragments into violence
okay and you have a title for your book
yet
working title geographies of justice :
caste and violence in colonial North
India and any estimated time of arrival
inshallah by the end of the summer I
hope I've crafted the final chapters and
then we'll see mocha wonderful thanks
very much for being with us with with us
here today
thanks very much Marilyn and it was a
pleasure speaking me for more
information about Professor Rai and of
course her research and newest book
please visit our website at Yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at